The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Good
morning, everyone.
So we have a singleton lecture
today on linear programming,
which is general purpose
optimization technique that you
can use to solve a
whole bunch of problems,
including ones that we've seen
in 6.046 and previously in 006.
And most recently, we
looked at max flow.
We wouldn't have had
to go through all
of that pain we went through
to derive a max flow algorithm
if you had a linear
programming package handy
and all you wanted to do was
find the optimum solution.
You could have just
run the linear program
with an appropriate
input, of course, that is
derived from the flow network.
And you'd get your
optimal solution.
And we'll spend a couple
of minutes on that
as we look at the power of
linear programming in today's
lecture.
But it's not just max flow.
You could do shortest paths.
You could do multi
commodity max flow,
which is more complicated
than max flow and a variety
of other problems.
So that's that good news.
The bad news is
that the algorithms
for linear programming are a
heck of a lot more complicated
than max flow.
And you can imagine that that
would be the case, because it's
a more general purpose and
more powerful technique.
The history really is that
it was an open problem.
Up until 1979, people did not
know if linear programming was
polynomial-time solvable
until Khachiyan came up
with this ellipsoid
method, and then there's
been progress sense.
But the algorithm we're going
to describe today and execute
on a example input is
a simplex algorithm--
the simplex algorithm--
that runs in worst case
exponential time.
But it's a very
efficient in practice.
And it's held its ground,
even with the advent
of more efficient, from
a theoretical sense,
polynomial-time algorithms,
namely the ellipsoid method,
which actually is not
that efficient in practice
and new interior point methods.
So a little bit
of context, let's
just dive into an
example of optimization
in the context of
politics and see
how you could formulate
this particular problem
as a linear program.
So how does politics work?
You buy elections, right?
So you don't want to
spend a lot of money,
so you want to minimize
the amount of money that
is required to buy an election.
And the way you buy an
election is, well, campaign,
but you advertise.
And it doesn't matter
facts that are relevant.
As long as you get to the right
demographic with the right
message, let's
assume that you're
going to win the election.
So that's our mathematical
abstraction pf campaigning
and politics all in 30 seconds.
So how to campaign
to win an election.
And as I said, we're
going to advertise.
But you do have a little
bit of work to do here.
That's why you need
your campaign manager.
And this manager is
going to estimate votes
obtained per dollar spent.
But that dollar is spent
advertising in support
of a particular case,
or a particular issue.
And contradictions are allowed.
As long as you're sending
different messages
to different demographics,
you're all good, right?
You're assuming
that people don't
watch more than one channel.
So you're a Fox News guy
or you're a MSNB guy.
You don't do both.
So now, we get at this estimate.
And it turns into a table.
And so you have your policy,
and you've got your demographic.
So you got urban, now
think Detroit, suburban,
I guess, you could
Lexington where you live,
and rural-- I really don't
have any idea what that means.
But presumably, there's places.
And here's our policy.
You want to build
roads-- kind of boring,
but some people are interested
in roads-- gun control,
of very sensitive,
farm subsidies--
you know who's interested
in that-- and gasoline tax--
kind of more, this
hits your pocket,
so more or less everybody's
interested in that.
So you tell the urban guys
you want to build roads,
and they don't like you.
So you get a minus 2 there.
So this can go, you
advertise, and it hurts you.
You lose votes.
Tell the suburban
people-- well, typically,
it's a situation where
you have these nice cars,
and you don't like
potholes, so you like roads
if you live in suburbia.
Rural people have 4-by-4's.
They don't particularly care.
They don't care as much.
Gun control-- well, you can
imagine that urban people
like that.
Suburban people
are, hm, OK, meh.
And the rural people
hate it, right?
You do not want to advertise on
gun control in the rural areas.
Farm subsidies-- so like,
don't want to deal with that.
What is a farm?
And the rural people
love it, right?
And then gasoline tax, well,
urban people are commuting.
And, well, they typically
don't have a lot of money.
So there you go.
And those are the numbers.
I'm not going to justify
every number here.
But you could put whatever
numbers you what, I mean.
So let's move on.
This is just a table.
It could have positive numbers.
It could have negative numbers.
And you still want
to win this election.
Regardless of how
crazy the demographics
are, how crazy
your electorate is,
you want to win the election.
So as long as you
have a great campaign
manager, who can
get you this table,
it's all mathematical
here on out.
You've just got
to figure out how
you're going to win a majority.
And you could argue that all
you want is to win the election.
We're going to do something
slightly different, which
is something that's obviously
going to guarantee victory.
But you want to win a
majority in every demographic.
As the tables may be off by
little, you want to be careful.
So the last thing,
of course, in order
to estimate how much money you
need is the population here.
So that's votes obtained
per dollar spent.
So you're getting-- it's
$10 a vote, it's $5 a vote,
et cetera.
And so we need to
translate that to votes,
because that's the dollars.
And you got your population
here corresponding
to each of these areas.
And that's what you got here.
Majority, we'll assume you
win in the case of ties,
just to keep these numbers easy,
so that's just divided by 2.
So that's what you got so far.
And you want to win by spending
the minimum amount of money.
So that's our
optimization problem.
So we can take this,
and we can convert it
to a set of linear equations.
And that's going to create
our linear program--
our first linear program.
And this is our algebraic setup.
And so let-- we need
some variables here,
so let x1, x2, x3, x4 denote
the dollars spent per issue.
So you got those
four issues up there.
So let me write that out.
It's important to
make sure you know
what I'm talking about with
respect to a particular issue.
So those are our four issues.
And those are our
four variables.
So this linear program
has four variables.
You're trying to discover
the values of these variables
to optimize, minimize
your cost function.
The second thing that
a linear program has--
and pretty much the only other
thing a linear program has--
are constraints.
And these constraints
are also linear.
It gets much more complicated if
you have quadratic constraints,
and we won't go there.
These constraints that I'm
going to write correspond
to this statement here that
says you want to majority
in each demographic.
So you can imagine that because
you have three demographics,
you're going to have
three constraints.
You could have written
this differently.
There's just any number
of variants here.
And you'll get the sense of
that as we go to other examples.
But we'll just stick
to one variant here.
So now, I want to
translate everything
that I've written in English
over there into algebra.
And so I got my minimization
criterion-- minimize x1 plus x2
plus x3 plus x4-- subject to
minus 2x1 plus 8x2 plus 0x3
plus 10x4 greater than
or equal to 50,000.
And this represents
the requirement
that I want a majority in
the first demographic, namely
the urban demographic.
And so I want at least
50,000 votes there.
And I need to spend
the money corresponding
to the values of x1
through x4 in such a way
that I get those 50,000 votes.
And that represents
that, and it's just
reading off the minus 2, 8, 0,
and 10 from the urban column.
So those numbers that you see
here correspond to the column,
because I'm talking about
the urban demographic.
And you can imagine
that the next constraint
is going to correspond to the
middle column, and the third
to the third.
So I'll just write that out.
I will call this constraint
the constraint number
1-- I might refer to it
later-- 5x1, plus 2x2 plus 0x3,
plus 0x4 greater than
or equal to 100,000.
Call this number two.
And then finally, 3x1
minus 5x2 plus 10x3.
And that's our set
of constraints,
but there's one
more little issue
that we have to be careful
about, if you're being precise,
and that is that there's no
notion of un-advertising.
And so you're going to
spend positive dollars.
And so x1 through x4 is
greater than or equal to 0.
So that's our first
linear program.
And it came from this
particular problem.
It'd be wonderful--
and that's exactly what
we're going to do for
the rest of the lecture--
if we could solve
this linear program
and any possible linear
program in an efficient way.
And so the number of
variables is small n.
And you can imagine that the
number of constraints here,
just talking about these
constraints, are m constraints.
And you certainly want at run
time that is polynomial in n.
That's our goal here.
And as I mentioned
early on, it was unclear
for the longest time-- well,
at least not until 1979,
but people had been
thinking about it
for a long time before
that-- as to whether there
was a general algorithm that
would solve any linear program
in time-polynomial in n.
And that was resolved
in '79 by Khachiyan.
We'll look at a algorithm as
simplex that in the worst case
runs exponentially in n
but is simpler to describe
and is very efficient
in practice.
So in our particular problem,
this one, it turns out you--
and I'm actually going to come
back to this in a second--
but I will just tell
you that the optimum
for this particular
linear program
with these particular numbers
correspond to these numbers
here.
So you want to spend something
of the order of $20,000
for-- so there's 100
here, so take away the two
0's-- so spend something of the
order of $20,000 for the first
issue, building roads, spend
a bit of money for the second
issue, ignore the third
corresponding to farm
subsidies, and spend a bit
of money for the gasoline tax
issue.
And these numbers aren't
important, other than the fact
that they happen to be optimum.
So if you add up these numbers,
then x1 plus x2 plus x3 plus x4
is something of the
order of $21,000--
$27,000, excuse me,
though I'm writing it out
as this fraction.
So important consideration
here is that these values xi
are real numbers.
That's it.
It's not that they
have to be integral.
Clearly, there
were fractions here
for the optimum,
some of them anyway.
But in general,
linear programming
says the variable
values are real.
There's also integer
linear programming,
which is NP complete, which
adds the additional constraint
that the xi values are integral.
So it turns into
a harder problem.
You got polynomial-time
solvable if the xi are real.
You got NP complete,
which Eric is
going to talk about on
Thursday, if the values are
forced to be integral.
So this extra constraint makes
things worse from a complexity
standpoint.
We won't talk about ILP anymore
for the rest of this lecture.
So I will come back to this.
And I'll talk about
how we can show
that this is optimum
without actually going
into a deep algorithmic dive.
But what I want to
do just before that
is to give you the
general formulation
of a linear program.
It's called the standard
form in CLRS, also called
the general form.
In some cases, we'll look
at the standard form for LP.
And I want to pop up a
level about this example
and give you the
general setting.
And we'll focus in on the
general setting for the most
part.
But what I have here is
I can either minimize
or maximize-- we
had a minimization
problem-- for the
political problem,
minimize the linear
objective function
subject to linear
inequalities or equations.
And the variables,
think of x as a vector,
it's a column vector, or
x1, x2, all the way to xn.
And the objective function is
c times x, so that's c1x1 dot,
dot, dot, cnxn.
And we just had all the
coefficients being a 1
over there.
And the inequalities,
they're the fun part,
you can represent
them as a matrix A,
so A times x less
than or equal to b.
And notice that this
is the standard form
that I'm talking about.
And now, I have
diverged from what
I had here, because
I had greater
than or equal to over here.
So it turns out, you'll
see linear programs
in different settings.
Sometimes, you'll
have minimization.
have maximization.
Sometimes, you'll have
less than constraints,
less than or equal
to constraints.
Sometimes, you'll have greater
than or equal to constraints.
Sometimes, you'll have
equality constraints.
We'll spend a little
bit of time talking
about how you can transform
any given linear program
into a standard form.
So our standard form is going
to be something that maximizes
the objective function.
So these are our
inequalities, and they're
represented as less
than or equal to.
That's the standard form.
And you want to maximize
c times x-- again,
max for standard-- such that
these set of inequalities
told Ax less than or equal
to b and x greater than
or equal to 0.
So for each of the values that
correspond to the variables,
you want these variables
to be non-negative
in the standard form.
And you want less than
or equal to corresponding
to each of the
inequalities-- not equal to,
not greater than or equal to,
but less than or equal to.
And you have this
linear cost function,
where you could have
arbitrary coefficients,
but you're maximizing it.
So that's it.
So it's all about polarities,
not much more than that.
It's just about polarities.
And if you get a linear program,
a specific linear program that
doesn't conform to this-- we'll
spend a few minutes talking
about conversions--
and it's going
to be fairly straightforward.
May not be immediately
obvious, but we'll get to that.
Any questions so far?
So I want to go
back to this claim
here, where I said
this is optimum.
Now without actually
describing an algorithm to you,
I'm going to be able
to show you, convince
you, that this value
here corresponding
to whatever it is, 3
million, 3.1 million,
is in fact optimum.
And this is
something I could do,
because linear programming
has this powerful notion
of duality.
So what is that?
Well, let's just first look
at our specific example here.
And I'll give you a very
specific observation.
I'm going to give
you what you can
think of as a certificate
of optimality.
I'm going to give you a
certificate of optimality
for that set of numbers.
And here's how I'm
going to do it.
So is there a short certificate?
I can imagine giving
you a long proof
that a particular linear
programming algorithm always
gives you the minimum
answer, the optimum answer,
walk through that,
executive that algorithm
on this particular
example, and then you're
convinced, of course,
that the solution is
going to be optimum.
But for this specific example, I
want to give you a certificate.
This certificate isn't going
to work for other examples.
It's going to short, because it
only works with this example.
But it won't work
for other ones.
And so how do I do that?
So the answer is,
in fact, there is
a certificate that shows that
the LP solution is optimal.
And consider that I compute this
particular algebraic quantity,
where all I've done is I've
taken these three equations
and I've multiplied them
by these magical constants.
And so I'm not going
to tell you how we get
this certificate of optimality.
But I'm going to give
you the certificate.
And it's going to
be clear that it's
a certificate of optimality.
And if I take these three
equations here, 1, 2, and 3--
actually, I refer to 1, 2, and
3, they refer to the equations.
These are equations
or constraints.
And so I take that.
And obviously, if I have
a bunch of equations
and I multiply them out, I
can certainly add them up,
and I get another
equation at the end of it.
And it's all going to be linear.
And if I do that,
I get x1 plus x2
plus 140 divided by
222 times x3 plus x4.
So that's what happens
to the left hand side.
And the right hand
side is-- you'll
recognize this quantity--
five 0's divided by 111.
That's what you get.
So now, can someone tell me
why in the last step, why
this is a certificate
of optimality--
the fact that obviously, this
is all algebra, once I've
discovered the coefficients--
so now that I've done this,
why have I just shown you that
3.1 million divided by 111
is, in fact, optimum?
Can someone tell me this?
Look at what you have
on the left hand side.
No?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Any other
solution would cost more
than the amount put in spent.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
Any other solution,
but I want you to relate
that to-- what am I spending?
AUDIENCE: You're
spending 3,100,000--
like, it's the same thing.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Yeah, but
I mean, this was a claim.
This was a claim-- and at
this point, an unproven claim.
It was an unproven claim.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You know that the left
hand side of that inequality
is less than or equal to
x1 plus x2 plus x3 plus x4.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Correct.
And what is x1 plus x2 plus
x3 plus x4, to be clear?
AUDIENCE: The thing
you're trying to minimize?
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Yeah,
exactly, the thing
you're trying to minimize.
Exactly.
You're almost there.
but the key observation here is
that x1 plus x2 plus x3 plus x4
is greater than or equal to x1
plus x2-- because all of these
are positive quantities,
remember-- 140 divided by 222,
that's less than 1,
x3 plus x4, correct?
So given that, I can say that
this is greater than our equal
to 3,100,000 111.
It's because of this
observation that it's
a certificate of optimality.
She has her head down, OK.
Great.
So that's pretty cool.
Just cooked up these
coefficients from somewhere,
pulled them out of
a hat, you're all
convinced now that the
value we got was optimum.
Did not run an algorithm.
Maybe I ran an
algorithm-- of course,
you ran an algorithm to get
those coefficients, right?
Well, how did those
coefficients appear?
So we're not going to spend
a whole lot of time on this.
You'll see this
likely in a problem
set or perhaps in section.
But in general, I won't
worry too much about duality,
other than knowing the concept.
And this notion of LP
duality essentially
says that what just happened
wasn't a coincidence.
You can do this all the time.
There will always be,
for a linear program,
a short certificate
of optimality
that corresponds to
some set of coefficients
that you can do this
particular math with by taking
these linear constraints,
multiplying them out, adding
them up together, and showing
that you have a lower bound
on-- in the case of this
problem-- you can't get lower
than this.
And therefore, for a
minimization problem,
when you reach that, you
clearly found the optimum.
And that's the
notion of LP duality.
And the basic theorem-- and
this is really more as an FYI,
we won't prove this
theorem-- is that if you
had the standard form for the
LP, which I'm just writing down
again here, where you had
Ax less than b, x vector
greater than or equal to 0.
So that's identically what
I had up here, or done here,
corresponding to the
standard LP form.
Well, there's a dual-- this is
what's called the primal form.
Usually, if you
don't say it, you
think of it as the primal form.
And if it's dual,
you call it a dual.
And this is primal form of LP.
This is a dual form
of LP, or dual LP.
And the dual LP
flips everything.
And it's not just
negation, but transposed,
and the actual variables
also swap functionalities.
So it's really pretty cool.
So your max turns into a min.
The c gets replaced by the
b, which is on the right hand
side of the inequalities.
And your constraints
are A transpose,
y greater than or equal to c.
So there's a flip there as well.
And y is greater
than or equal to 0.
So there's a bunch of
things that's going on here.
And these two problems
end up being equivalent--
the primal and the dual,
you can always do this.
And essentially, what
is happening here
is that you're solving these
two problems simultaneously.
And there's lots
of algorithms that
keep flipping between these
two forms for efficiency.
But ultimately, what
ends up happening is
you see that the actual
constraints that you had here
corresponding to the b
constraints turn into-- the b
ends up in the
cost function here.
And that's essentially
what's happening out here
with respect to multiplying
these equations out
with particular coefficients.
So as I said, this is
really more as an FYI.
This is an obviously interesting
and an interesting proof
of optimality, which is
a different kind of proof
from proving an
algorithm correct
and applying that proof
to a particular instance.
That's the kind of
thing that happens
in LP, especially when you flip
from primal and dual forms.
So I'll leave it at that.
What I'd like to do
is give you a sense
of how we can convert
to standard form,
so you can apply an algorithm
that-- for example, you
have a program and it only
requires standard form.
It runs on standard form.
Let's go over it really quickly.
This is not going to take
very long-- a translation
from different kinds of LPs--
and we had a slightly different
here for our political problem
that had a minimization--
and how would we convert
that to standard form.
So it's probably just one
conversion here that's tricky.
So suppose I want to
minimize minus 2x1 plus 3x2,
and I want to convert
it to standard formal.
All I have is a
standard LP solver.
What do I do?
It should be easy.
What do I do if I had a
solver that was maximizing,
but I want to
minimize a quantity?
Just switch the signs, right?
So negate to 2x1 minus
3x2 and maximize.
So that was easy.
This is a tricky one.
Suppose xj does not have a
non-negativity constraint.
So it just happens to be the
case that it's not dollars
but it's some other quantity
that can go negative.
It might be profit or loss.
So that quantity
represents profit and loss,
so it could go
negative if it's loss.
So I don't have this constraint
in my original problem
specification.
But my standard form
and my LP solver
requires this entire
vector to be non-negative.
So I got a problem here.
I can't use my standard
solver, because
of this non-negativity
constraint.
So how do I fix that?
How do I turn it into a problem
that allows the standard solver
to be used?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You can break
it up into two variables,
like xj1 and xj2, so
xj1 minus xj2 equals xj,
and both could have [INAUDIBLE].
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Perfect,
great, that's good.
Here you go.
So what you do here is take
xj and replace it with,
let's say, xj prime
minus xj double prime.
And you have xj prime
greater than or equal to 0,
xj double prime greater
than or equal to 0.
But depending on the
particular values
in whatever solution
you're exploring
are the final solution, you
may have an actual xj value
that's negative or positive.
So you added an extra variable
here to your linear program.
And a couple more
real quick, suppose
that I have an equality
constraint corresponding
to x1 plus x2 equals 7.
What do I do with an
equality constraint
where I have x1
plus x2 equals 7?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You can say x1 plus x2
is greater than or equal to 7,
and x1 plus x2 is less
than or equal to 7.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: No, you
can't do less than or equal to.
AUDIENCE: But then you
can flip the signs to--
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Ah, then
you could flip the signs.
So you have two
steps there, good.
So your less than or equal
to needs another multiplier.
So what you end up doing is
something like x1 plus x2
greater than or equal to 7.
And then you need-- if you
do what the gentleman just
said-- and flip the sign,
you get minus x1 minus x2
greater than or
equal to minus 7.
Is that right?
No?
I messed up?
Oh, I want less
than or equal to.
You're right, you're right.
So I need less than or equal
to-- that's right, of course,
thank you.
So I need less than or
equal to in both places.
So that's the standard form.
I needed less than or equal to.
Good.
What you've done is increased
the number of constraints
by one.
Did I get this right
the second time?
All right.
So that's pretty much it.
The last thing, which I
won't really write out,
is, which we've done here
already, greater than
or equal to constraint
translated-- I won't give you
an example of this;
we have this already--
translates to less than or
equal to by minus 1 multiplied.
So we have to
invoke that in order
to do the equality anyway.
So you're in business.
If you have a
standard LP solver,
you can take pretty much any
optimization problem that
is linear in terms of
its objective function
and has linear constraints, and
you can transform it into LP.
If you had non-linear
constraints,
there's lots of
work that goes on
in linearizing those constraints
and using LP solvers.
It's a very practical
thing to do.
It may be something you'll
end up doing, invoking
these powerful LP solvers--
typically, they're commercially
available; the best
ones are commercial--
and use it to solve
your particular problem.
It turns your algorithm design
problem into a reduction.
And so you'll spend really
the next couple of weeks
thinking about reductions.
We'll start that
up right now, where
we'll take existing
combinatorial
problems, for which we
already know algorithms for,
and you're going to
reduce them to LP.
Just to give you a sense
of what the power of LP
is, but this notion of
reduction is very powerful,
you can use it to do
complexity proofs.
Here, we're just using it as a
convenience in today's lecture
to use our LP hammer.
So let's say that I have
our favorite problem
of the week, namely max flow.
And I want to
convert that to LP.
So go back a week ago, and right
about this time a week ago,
and we'd set up the
max flow problem.
And let's assume that
we went back there.
And we didn't talk
about augmenting paths,
and we didn't talk about
residual capacities or min-cut
or anything like that,
but we knew LP already.
And we just want to
solve max flow using LP.
So let's do that.
So this is maximum flow.
I'm not going to bother with
converting to standard form.
We know how to do that,
given what we just
did here, over there.
So I'll just do whatever I
want to keep things simple.
Max flow is obviously
a maximization problem.
And using the same
notation we've used,
it's not going to
look like Ax and b,
just because I want you to
recall what max flow is.
And we're going
to translate that.
And the values of
these variables--
or the names of these variables,
whether they're x or f,
it should really matter.
We know how to do LP
at this point-- we
know how to formulate LP, I
should say, at this point.
And we're assuming that
we have an LP solver.
So what I want to do here
with the maximum flow problem
is maximizing the flow value.
And it's simply,
you grab the source,
you have a variable associated
with the flow from the source
to every other vertex of v.
And you have to maximize that.
So that was the
setup for max flow.
I'm not changing that.
What do you think the three
constraints, or whatever
set of constraints
that we have here,
are going to
correspond to the LP?
You spent a week
on max flow, looked
at the problem set,
what constraints am I
going to have to put up there?
I'm going to have to put
up capacity constraints.
That's an obvious one.
What is another one?
Conservation constraints.
All flow entering a node that
is not the source or the sink
has to leave it.
In the original
network, is there
a concept of negative flow?
No, you will define it going
in the other direction.
So we did talk about
negative numbers, et cetera,
but you're going to have
positive quantities, especially
if you look at net flow,
the version of the flow
that we zoomed in on in the
Tuesday lecture from last week.
And you also have-- in
the general setting,
you're going to have these skew
symmetry constraints as well.
So the three things
that you need here
are skew symmetry,
conservation, and capacity.
So you have such that f u, v
equals minus f v, u for all u,
v belonging to V.
And depending on the kind
of network that you have,
if you constrain
it to a sudden type
that you don't have
these two-way edges,
you could certainly
remove some, if not all,
of these skew
symmetry constraints.
Important ones are
conservation and capacity.
And this should seem
pretty familiar to you.
But the key-- the reason
I'm writing these all out
is primarily to ensure that you
understand that these are all
linear constraints.
So that's pretty
much the only thing
that you need to observe here.
Obviously, these
constraints you've
seen many a time from the
two lectures last week.
But notice that
they're all linear.
And finally, this one is f u,
v less than or equal to c of u,
v for all u, v
belonging to cap V.
So this is f.
That's a variable that's
less than another constant,
clearly linear.
Doing a bunch of sums here.
I could obviously have
multipliers, scalar
multipliers.
In this case, for
conservation, I
don't have scalar multipliers,
but clearly linear.
Skew symmetry, got
two variables in here.
One of them is a negation of
the other, clearly linear,
so that's why this is an LP.
And so you might say,
well, I know better,
max flow is much more
efficient than any LP
solver that's out there.
And you would be right.
If you have a max flow
problem of this variety,
it's difficult to
imagine that you
would get performance, empirical
performance from running an LP
solver.
But this generalization
of max flow
that's a multi-commodity max
flow, where you just don't have
one commodity flowing through.
You may be counting cars
and trucks on a road,
or there's two different
kinds of liquid
flowing through the same
pipe, whatever, gas or liquid.
And so when you have
multiple commodities,
you may have a linear but
more complicated cost function
that's a function of the flow
of each of the commodities.
And they may have a certain
weight associated with them.
So there's a lot of
things that could
be more general-- there could
be more general settings
corresponding to max flow.
And I'll just leave
you with the thought
that you could simply
have two commodities.
And we'll just
call them 1 and 2.
And so now, you have the f1's
and the c1's and the f2's and
the c2's.
Each commodity has
to be conserved.
But what about the capacity?
What do you think happens
with the capacity?
Let's just assume these are
two different kinds of cars.
So what would the capacity
constraint look like?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can
say either c1 or f1
plus f2 is-- for each edge,
you can add them together
or you might take the
linear [INAUDIBLE].
SRINIVAS DEVADAS:
Exactly, that's right.
So good point.
It may be the case that I
have distinct capacities.
And in fact, if you have
completely disjoint problems,
you're right in that you
can solve them separately.
But actually, the
more interesting case
would be that you have
a single capacity c,
so you'll have-- let me
just write this out here.
If in fact you had
two distinct things,
so if you had f1, c1,
f1, c2, the question
is, do you have two distinct,
disjoint optimizations,
in which case you just
use max flow twice.
On other hand, what's
more interesting really--
and I should've used this
example for starters--
but here's a better one.
You have two commodities
and a single capacity.
So the road is a good example.
Both the cars and the
trucks share the same road.
It has a certain capacity.
And now, your
capacity constraint
is looking like f1
plus f2 over here.
And that's the flow through
the particular edge uv.
So you have something
like f1 u, v plus f2 u,
v is less than or equal to c
u, v for this total capacity.
And that's pretty much it.
So that is linear.
The nice thing is
that it's linear.
You could put weights on it.
If you wanted to claim
that a particular commodity
1 uses up-- because
it's a truck,
it uses up more
space on the road.
And you can accommodate
fewer of them.
You could put a
multiplier in there.
Still say it's linear.
So that's the power of
by having an LP engine.
You could translate
problems that
are not exactly max flow,
that are multi-commodity flow.
You may have additional linear
constraints that you could add,
and you could still
use your LP package.
So that's the reason why this
is interesting and powerful.
So that is kind of an obvious,
corresponding to max flow.
Let's look at something
that's a little less obvious.
And it's going to be a little
tricky to convert the shortest
path problem to LP,
not a lot of work
but one little
observation that's
going to be important to make
in order for the whole thing
to flow through or
actually work out.
So we all know the
shortest path problem.
We want to find-- let's just
call it the single source
shortest path problem.
You have a specific source.
That's going to turn into
the point from which you're
going to start
computing the distance.
That's what Dijkstra does,
and that's Bellman-Ford does.
And so this is from vertex
x-- s, excuse me, s.
And what I want to do here
is obviously set it up
as a set of linear constraints.
If I have dv corresponding to
the distance from the source--
so dv represents the
distance from the source--
and eventually I want
dv to be the shortest
distance from the source.
That's our notation
for shortest paths.
dv represents an existing
path-- it may not
be the shortest path-- from
s to v, the value of that.
But dv monotonically
decreases as you run through.
It's initially
infinity in Dijkstra
going back to Dijkstra.
And then we shrink it through
a process of relaxation.
Now I want to try and model
that-- I want to try and model
all of this as an LP.
So it's not
immediately obvious--
the thing that the
flow networks had,
where we had these constraints.
We have capacity constraints
and conservation constraints.
And we could turn that
constraint into an inequality.
And it was pretty smooth.
It's pretty easy.
So what I need to do
here with shortest paths
is something that's
a little more subtle.
So what basic constraint do
I have in a shortest path
algorithm?
What's an inequality--
you remember an inequality
from shortest paths that
we kept talking about?
The triangle inequality.
So we're going to have to go
with the triangle inequality
and take the triangle inequality
and use that to create an LP
formulation of shortest paths.
In particular, what
we have here is
that I could write
dv minus du is
less than or equal to w u, v
for all u, v belonging to E.
And that's the
triangle inequality.
And I'm going to
have d of s equals 0.
That's the only thing
that I start with.
And so what's happening
out here is simply
that there's different
ways of getting
to v. And my shortest path
is going to be the best
way of getting to
v. So in particular,
the way you want to think about
this is that if I have a v
and I can get to it from,
let's just say, u1 and u2.
And maybe the
source is over here.
And these are the only two
edges that can get to v.
So I'm just looking at a
fairly limited setting.
u1 and u2 are going to have
to be the two vertices.
One of these two is
going to get me to v.
And I got w u1, v here.
And I got w u2, v over here.
And so what this
is saying is, I'm
going to have to write this
out for each of these edges.
For each of these edges, I'm
going to have this constraint.
And that's says that the dv
value, if I want the shortest
path, should obey both
of these constraints.
And if I want to obey both of
these constraints, one of them
is going to be my
limiting constraint.
And I'm going to get
the min of those two.
Correct?
So in effect what
this translates to
is that it's an AND, right?
So dv have minus du1 is
less than or equal to w u1,
v. dv minus du2 is less than
or equal to w u2, v. That's
an AND, because I'm putting both
of those constraints in here.
And that essentially
means that dv
is going to be the min
of the two quantities--
the du1 quantity
plus the w u1, v,
and the du2 quantity plus
the w u2, v. That make sense?
Ask me questions
if this is unclear.
So that simply
corresponds to the fact
that I'm doing an AND over here.
I'm adding all of these
constraints in there.
So I'm applying the triangle
inequality to every edge,
to every relationship
between a vertex that
has a path ending at it.
And you're pushing it
forward to this vertex v,
all the different ways that
you can get to v. In this case,
there is two sets of ways--
one from u1 and one from u2.
And the last step is
a minimization step.
So you think you're
done or we're done,
but we're not quite
done, because what's
missing here in terms
of my formulation of LP?
What else do I have to do here?
Well, sure, non-negative--
let's do that.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Objective.
SRINIVAS DEVADAS: Objective,
who said objective?
You again?
So we are missing an
objective function.
Now shortest path is what
kind of problem again?
Short means minimum?
Minimum, height whatever.
So do I put a-- what happens
if I put a minimum in here?
And let's say that I
do something like sigma
over V, cap V, dv, because
I want to minimize--
or I could pick
a particular one.
I could pick a particular single
source, single destination,
and I put a minimum there.
What happens?
Does this work?
What's the solution
to this problem,
if I minimize the distance?
0, because the zero
value is going to work.
So there's something-- I
haven't put in the constraint
that I do want a path.
I do want a path from
s to v for any v that
matches one of the
quantities in the min,
because the min says
I have equality.
The big issue here is, this
is a less than or equal to,
and that's why the min doesn't
work in the objective function.
It's a less than or equal to.
But this min over here, which
is the definition of a shortest
path, is saying that it's
either equal to this quantity
or equal to that quantity.
There's an equality over here
that is missing from this side.
And that's the key observation.
Once you observe that,
that need equality
for one of these constituent
quantities of the min,
then you'll see that
what you have to do
is simply change
this min to a max.
So you say, well,
how the heck did
a min get changed into a max?
And I'm not sure I'm going
to convince every on of you
in the next minute or so.
But the bottom line
is, it comes down
to I do have a min already
in my inequalities,
because I'm ANDing each
of these inequalities,
and I'm putting down each of
those inequalities in there.
So each of them is going to
force me to find the best
solution, because they're
going to constrain me to not
go via u2 if u1 is better,
because the other constraint
corresponding to u1 is
going to force me down.
So there's an
additional min in there,
because the ANDing of the
less than or equal tos.
And then in order to actually
force the equality for one
of those, I need to push
up as hard as I can,
or as high as I can.
So think about it.
Play around with a
couple of examples.
Choose a simple
example for starters.
And you'll see that this
is the correct formulation.
So you can see that it's not
completely clear in some cases
how to transform problems to LP.
But even in those cases,
sometimes you can.
So there's just a ton
of different problems,
a good skill to have
to be able to take
combinatorial
optimization engines,
like LP or even max flow, and
be able to translate problems
to them.
It's something that
you'll probably
do if you stick to
algorithms in your careers
or exploiting available
algorithm packages.
So the last thing I want to do
here for the rest of the time
is to give you some sense for
how an LP program is actually
optimized.
How can you possibly take
the standard LP formulation,
which is a general setting.
You know nothing
about shortest paths,
let's assume, nothing
about max flow.
It's not about a
specific problem.
It's about the general setting.
How can we solve
the general setting,
because that was the
theme here anyway.
You had this engine, and
you want to use this engine.
But now, how do you
build this engine?
So what we're going to do is
look at a fairly simple example
of the simplex algorithm.
And this algorithm
is in the textbook.
And it'll be in my notes.
So I'll get as far as I can.
It's not that complicated
to describe, especially
from an example standpoint.
But I may not get
through all of the steps
to get you the optimum for
this particular example
given how much time we have.
The most important
concept in simplex
is yet another form
of representation
for simplex, which says that
you can represent the LP, not
in standard form,
but in slack form.
So I'm going to tell
you what slack form is.
And then what we're
going to do is,
the flow of simplex,
algorithmic flow,
is to convert one slack
form into and equivalent.
Obviously, you don't want to
do something that's incorrect,
but it has to be
an equivalent slack
form, whose objective value has
not decreased and has likely
increased.
So you're guaranteed that
the objective value has not
decreased.
You're not guaranteed
that it's increased.
And then we're going to keep
going till the optimal solution
becomes obvious.
And you might say,
how is this obvious?
That's the reason why I talked
about the short certificate
of optimality.
It's definitely a relationship
between the termination
of simplex and the fact
that you can now say,
hey, I know I'm done
here, it's kind of obvious
that I can't do any better.
And hopefully, you'll see that
by the end of this lecture
in this simple example.
So that's it.
It's an iterative algorithm.
It's exponential,
unfortunately, because this
takes m plus n, choose n
iterations in the worst case,
where n is the
number of variables
and m is the number
of constraints.
Most of the time, it
does a lot better,
but that's the only bound
that you can actually
prove in the worst case.
And so you're stuck with
an exponential algorithm
if you're using
simplex worst case.
We won't actually do
much analysis on simplex.
It's really out of scope for
046 in terms of the analysis.
The actual algorithm is
certainly within scope.
So what I want to do is
give you some sense for what
the slack form looks like.
And we'll do a couple of
iterations of simplex.
And we'll get as far as we can
before the end the lecture.
So we'll take a
different example
from our political example.
It's similar in size.
And I want to explain to
you what the slack form is
and why it's interesting.
So what I want to do is maximize
3x1 plus x2 plus x3 subject
to the constraints that
x1 plus x2 plus 3x2
is less than or equal to
30, 2x1 plus 2x2 plus 5x3 is
less than or equal to 24,
4x1 plus x2 plus 2x3 less
than or equal to 36, and then
non-negativity constraints,
x1, x2, x3 greater
than or equal to 0.
So that's our example problem.
I'll leave it up there.
You're going to convert
this to slack form.
And so what is the slack form?
We're going to introduce an
additional number of variables
that correspond to the number
of equations that we have.
So we're going to introduce,
in this case, three new labels,
because I have three equations.
And the slack for this
problem looks like this.
I'm going to have z
equals 3x1 plus x2
plus x3, same as before.
And then I'm going
to have variables
that represent-- these are
called basic variables.
And the original variables are
called non-basic variables.
So I'm going to add three
basic labels, x4, x5,
and x6, corresponding to
these three constraints.
And they're going to
represent slack in the sense
that they're going to
correspond to how much slack you
have in the
inequalities that you
have in the original problem.
So if x4 happens to be
0, then you're jammed up.
You have no slack, because x1
plus x2 plus 3x3 equals 30.
And increasing any one of them
will violate the constraint.
So that's just simply
the notion of slack.
It's how much room do you have.
x5 is 24 minus 2x1
minus 2x2 minus 5x3.
And the last one
is 36 minus 4x1.
This is very mechanical
up to this point.
And so I'll call this set
of equations, equation I.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to now work on a space that
corresponds to x1, x2, x3, x4,
x5, x6.
So I'm going to have
these solutions that
now have six values
associated with them,
as opposed to just three
values, because I've
added three variables, the basic
variables, to my non-basic set.
So the original
variables are non-basic,
just to differentiate.
So so far it's just
set up its definitions.
We can think about up running
through iterations of simplex.
It takes about three
iterations here
in order to get to the point
where the optimum is obvious.
So you're going to convert
through three slack forms.
And then finally, when you
get to this fourth slack form,
you see that you have
an optimal solution.
And how does that work?
You're going to have the notion
of a basic solution, where
we set all non-basic
variables to 0.
So in this case, what
we're going to have--
and then we're going to compute
values of the basic variables.
So our objective function
here is going to be 3 times
0 plus 1 times 0 plus 2 times
0, which is obviously 0.
And the values x4,
of course, is going
to be-- because all of these
are 0-- is going to be 30.
x5 is going to be 24.
And x6 is going to be 36.
So this is kind of a
trivial starting point.
So you can think
of this as 0, 0, 0,
the solution that you're
looking at, 30 24, and 36.
So that's our starting
point, which doesn't really
tell you much.
But now comes the
key step, where
we're going to do something
that's called pivoting.
And in pivoting,
you're going to swap
a basic able with a
non-basic variable.
It is a step that requires
some intelligence.
But the basic step is a swap.
So one of the basic
variables is going
to become a non-basic
variable and vice versa.
And how do we select this?
Initially, you can kind of
do this in an arbitrary way.
It gets a little more
subtle as you go along.
You don't want to do
things in a random way.
But let's just start with
what pivoting actually
does in a more generic setting.
The basic step is select a
non-basic variable-- let's
call it x sub e-- who's
coefficient in the objective
function is positive.
You can always redefine things
if you can't find something
like that.
But we won't go there.
And then what we're
going to do is
we're going to increase the
value of x as much as possible.
And we always have
constraints, of course.
So we can do that
without violating
any of the constraints.
And then at this point,
variable xe becomes basic.
So it's going to turn
into the left hand side.
It's going to move over.
You're going to swap-- the x1
might be over here, over here,
and you got to rewrite these
equations so the x1 becomes
basic, for example, over
to the left hand side,
and the variable
that it replaced
goes over to the
right hand side.
So you can think of this
as Gaussian elimination,
except with inequalities.
There's definitely
relationships there,
if you recall your
Gaussian elimination.
If you don't, don't
worry about it.
So xe becomes basic,
and some other variable
becomes non-basic.
The values of other
basic variables
and the objective
function may change.
So we'll do one
pivot step at least,
so you get a sense for
the algebra involved.
And it becomes a
little more concrete.
To motivate you
further, you'll be
doing this in problem set
8 on a different example.
So what did I do
here is we're going
to select a non-basic variable.
So let's just select
x1, lexicographic order
or numeric order, let's
select x1 is selected.
That's the non-basic variable.
And what I want to do is
increase the value of x1.
So I want to increase it
without violating constraints.
Now, which of these
constraints do you think
is going to cause trouble
first with respect
to increasing the value of x1?
x1 is now 0.
We're at ground level, we have
all 0, things are feasible.
Now, as I start
increasing x1, remember,
you have non-negativity
constraints
associated with each of
the x4 values as well.
That's what these basic
variables represent.
So don't forget the fact that
the constraints are violated.
You need all the xi's to be
greater than or equal to 0.
That was true for the
non-basic variables.
It's also true for
the basic variables.
So a violation of a
constraint implies
that one of the currently
basic variables goes negative.
That's exactly equivalent
to the original inequality
not being satisfied.
So which of these
constraints, do you think,
is going to cause trouble here?
Just look at it, and should
be able to look at the three
equations and tell me, as
I increase the value of x1,
where am I going
to hit my limit?
x6, yes, absolutely correct.
So that's because
of the minus 4 here.
This is a big multiplier.
I got a minus 1 here, a minus
2 here, and a minus 4 here.
And if we just look at 4, the
magnitudes, 4 is bigger than 2
and is bigger than
1, so it's going
to be that third constraint.
So third constraint--
you can obviously
compute this numerically
or mechanically.
It was just easier to do this in
this example by eyeballing it.
And so third constraint
is the tightest one.
And it limits how much
we can increase x1.
So I'm going to
do my second step
up there, which
corresponds to rewriting
x1 as these other variables.
And now, I got x1 on the
left hand side and x6
on the right hand side.
And now, it's just merely
a matter of substitution.
Once I've done this, I'm just
going to jam through and go in
and I'm going to rewrite
the other equations with x6
on the right hand side.
And that is, I'm
going to replace x1
with the eyeball equation.
And that's really a
simple substitution.
So at this point,
what's happened
is, because the third
constraint representing x6
was the one that was
chosen, what's happened
is that x1 and x6 are
going to interchange roles.
x1 was non-basic, it's
going to become basic.
x6 was basic and is going
to become non-basic.
And that's basically the essence
of the simplex algorithm.
The iteration and then the
convergence and all of that
is, as I mentioned, going to
require getting to a point
where the optimality
is obvious, but we
won't be doing any
proofs corresponding
to conversions for simplex
or any other specific LP
techniques in this class.
Maybe some constraint
techniques,
I take back what I said, but
certainly not for simplex.
But I just want to give you
a sense for the flow here.
And so let's just go through
this last thing here in terms
of finishing off the pivot xi's.
And I want to show you what
the equations look like.
And if you just keep doing that,
at some point, you'll converge.
And so what happens
here is you have z
equals 27 plus x2 divided
by 4 plus x3 divided
by 2 minus 3x6 divided by 4.
x1 equals-- so there's
a bunch of algebra
here that I'm obviously skipping
over, but it's simple algebra.
And I have x4 over
here, 21 minus 3x2
divided by 4 minus 5x3 divided
by 2 plus x6 divided by 4,
and then one last thing here.
So that's my pivot step,
that I've flipped x1 and x6.
So now you ask,
what was the point?
What was the point of this?
Well, the point of this was
that you actually increased
the objective function value
and, in this particular case,
quite significantly, while
maintaining correctness.
And so let me just make these
observations and conclude here,
because then that gets us to
the point where you've seen
the details of one pivot step.
And you can imagine applying it
over and over to a convergence.
And let's just look at the
original basic solution,
which as you recall was
0, 0, 0, 30, 24, and 36.
And this is simply
x1 through x6.
This original basic
solution suddenly
satisfies these
equations-- equations II,
if you just put them in there.
And it makes sense that it will
have the objective value of 0,
given equivalents,
but you can verify
that by saying
that you have 27--
the original had the
objective value of 0,
because all the x
sub 1, x2, x3 were 0,
so that was an easy check in the
set of equations corresponding
to the first set, which
I've erased at this point.
But no matter.
And if you look at what I
have here, I have 36 equals 0.
So the objective
value here is 0.
It matches what you had before.
But the basic
solution for II, I'm
going to set the
non-basic values.
So what is a solution here?
The non-basic values are 0.
So the solution is going to
be 9, because 9 is non-basic.
x1 is now non-basic.
x2 and x3 are still basic.
And then I have 21 and 6.
And x6 now has become basic.
So the way I get this solution
is simply by plugging in 0's
on this aside.
And I get 9, 21, and 6,
because I just plugged
in 0's on the right hand side.
So that's how I
got a new solution.
And if you look at the
objective value for this,
the objective value, you can
look at this objective value
simply by looking at
the original problem.
And the original problem
had 3x1 plus x2 plus x3
as the objective value.
And so if you go off and you
see, well, that you had 0's
for the other ones,
but you have 3 times 9,
so we have an
objective value of 27.
So this flip of
our pivot basically
got you from an
objective value of 0,
while maintaining correctness,
to an objective value of 27.
And you can look at this
in the notes or in CLRS,
but you have to do two
more pivots corresponding
to two other variables--
the same grungy
stuff that I went through here,
substitution after selection.
And the objective value
is going to increase.
And you might ask, how
do I know that I'm done?
And so that was the
last thing here,
which is increase the value
until it becomes obvious-- no,
this was pivoting, I'm sorry--
increase the value pivot
until it becomes obvious
what the optimum is.
And what ends up
happening is you end up
with an objective function.
In this case, the objective
function mind you,
this thing over here is
the objective function.
And notice that it has
a negative coefficient
on the variable
that was actually
the part of the first pivot.
So x1 and x6 were a
part of the first pivot.
And this got a
negative coefficient.
So what ends up happening here
is you end up getting something
like 30 minus something
minus something
minus something, where you
have xi values over here.
And when you set these to be
0, that's the best you can do,
because these are all
negative quantities.
So I'll just leave
you with that.
Hopefully, you understood
how we do the pivoting--
sub through it three
times, and then
you get that objective function,
and the optimum value is 30.
See you next time.